[Musik]
hallo herr zwanziger ließ welt heute
habe ich eine ganz schnelle
lastminute.de für euch und zwar einen
zehn minuten ananas kokos teil der
kuchen oder dabei die tat ich weiß nicht
so genau wie ich den kuchen oder das
dessert bezeichnen soll jedenfalls
besteht er sie es aus einem keks boden
des rother kekse mit butt butterkekse
mit butter vermischen
doch bestimmt dann habe ich im inneren
eine ananas führung mit mascarpone und
obendrauf eine schicht vanille sahne und
kokos so lockt kokosflocken mein gott
was ist denn heute mit - jetzt ganze
garten braucht sagte er der kuchen
gelingt und vor allem ist es wirklich
ein superschnelles rezept und sehr
leichtes rezept wenige zutaten und ich
habe das tatsächlich auch aus meinem
vorratsschrank einfach alles rausgeholt
denn ich habe an anders aus der dose
verwendet seine habe ich immer da
butterkekse butter habe ich auch immer
alles da und deswegen kann ich diese
torte diese tat oder den teig ihrer zeit
zu bereiten und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal die zutaten an zutaten
braucht er ist 200 gramm futter hexe 100
gramm butter für die füllung habe ich
hier eine dose ananas bereits abgetropft
etwas von electric 250 gramm mascarpone
ein päckchen sommerbad und davon habe
ich zwei teelöffel für den belag für den
belag brauche ich nämlich 200 gramm
sahne die zwei teelöffel seiner fahrt
und 80 zum castor erstmal mein leben ich
jetzt die butter und die komplizin top
und die lasse ich jetzt bei geringer
hitze etwas schnell
ihr könnt zum beispiel auch eine
mikrowelle nehmen aber die haben wir
nicht jetzt sind die kekse an der reihe
und die kekse könnte jetzt entweder in
einem gefrierbeutel film und darin
zerkleinern oder nehmt einfach einen
kleinen rückfall so
[Musik]
sobald ihr futter geschmolzen ist kommen
jetzt die qsc hier betreiben und werden
einfach gut durchgeführt
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier eine 20 cm tat frau
mit her geboten
der boden ist dafür da dass ich die tage
später ganz leicht wieder rauszukommen
und die tat form die fed ich jetzt ein
bisschen wachstumsproblem die tat noch
leichter tun und ich hier kommt jetzt
die kids mischung rein und dann werde
ich sie jetzt mit den ganz flach drücken
und auch einen rand hochziehen
ich habe jetzt hier übrigens ganz
normale butterkekse und auch
vollkornkekse gemischt und ihr könnt
dann wirklich auch eure lieblings kekse
nehmen also alles was ihr möchtet es
müssen auch keine mutter kirche sein das
kann auch löffelbiskuits zum beispiel
seien wirklich alles was ihr da hat
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der boden kommt jetzt schon mal in den
kühlschrank danke und ich kann das schon
mit der füllung weitermachen war ja
alles noch heute in einem technisch
natürlich immer schön sauber machen
das habe ich auch schon eltern auf dem
messeturm gebeten sally bitte sag den
kindern dass es zwischendurch auch sauer
einfach zwischendurch immer sauber sind
sauber arbeitsplatz sein wird auch
gleich schon jetzt mache ich erstmal mit
erfüllung weiter dafür nehme ich jetzt
wie ananas stücke sie kommen jetzt hier
rein und werden jetzt kurz probiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir kommen jetzt die mascarpone mit rein
und das vanille extrakt das sagt
natürlich für den leckeren geschmack und
auch das saunabad und dann nämlich jetzt
auch eine ganze packung damit die creme
auch wirklich fest wird denn ananas hat
ihr wirklich viel flüssigkeit hatte zwar
ein bisschen ausgedrückt aber dennoch
sehr gut und jetzt einfach alles mit dem
sich mir wesen verrühren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und wenn ihr merkt dass sich die gremien
bis hin zu fest ist könnt ihr auch noch
ein bisschen von dem an annas tod mit
rein geben aber ich finde so ideal
die creme stelle ich jetzt chris kühn
und werde jetzt gleich mit die sahne
steif schlagen
das mache ich auch mit etwas vanille
extrakt und seiner tat stellt die sahne
auch kühl und dann können wir gleich die
tat zusammen schichten okay jetzt war
der wahrscheinlich ein bisschen verwirrt
ich habe jetzt gerade hier aufgeräumt
und gemerkt ich hatte gar keinen seiner
partner stehen sondern kraftstoff das
ehrlich sagt eben erst aufgefallen als
ich dich erwischt habe ich habe einfach
falsche schublade gegriffen und sagt
stopp geholt stoff seiner fahrt aber das
ist gar nicht schlimm ich kann euch
jetzt mal kurz die produkte vielleicht
erklären sagt stopp das besteht aus
weizenstärke und das ist dafür da könnt
ihr auch böden zum beispiel damit
bestreuen und dann weichen die eben
nicht durch wenn da zb ochs drauflegt
was wirklich viel feuchtigkeit intent
saunapark hat noch den vorteil dass noch
ein bisschen zucker mit dabei das heißt
wenn ich seine starke dann muss ich
keinen zusätzlichen zucker mit dazu
geben außer ich möchte es und jetzt
lasse ich einfach in der erfüllung des
safts stock mit drin jetzt habe ich ja
auch schon drin das ist völlig okay
vor allem habe ich da jetzt kein zucker
mit dabei denn die ananas ist er
wirklich schon süß genug zum sahne
schlagen nehmen jetzt allerdings die
sommerpartys paßlick ist mit dem
besseren egal
jetzt habe ich kurz auf und schlage
jetzt gleichsam
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt wird die tat zusammen gesetzt hier
sitzt die füllung bis hin zu fest die
zieht ja auch im kühlschrank noch ein
bisschen an das heißt ich gebe es noch
ein bisschen sirup mit rein
ich habe hier eine mango sirup aber wie
gesagt könnte ja auch diesen ananas
sirup aufheben aus der dose und es ganz
einfach noch mal verloren
[Musik]
und wenn euch die konsistenz dann gut
gefällt kann das ganze jetzt hier auf
dem vorbereiteten tortenboden die tat
also wirklich super schnell gemacht oder
dabei zu sein sonst hardtop könnt auch
wirklich so als last minute idee zum
dessert zubereiten und jetzt einfach
kurz verteilen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt kommt hier noch die steif
geschlagene sahne obendrauf und dann
bedenklich das ganze mit kokosraspeln
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und so stelle ich die tat jetzt für
mindestens eine halbe stunde aber besser
für eine stunde in den kühlschrank
[Musik]
zitat ist jetzt gut durch gekühlt jetzt
nehme ich hier eine kleine schüssel und
so lässt sie sich wirklich einfach aus
der form herauslösen
ganz vorsichtig bis zu schieben also von
unten schiebe ich jetzt praktisch diese
geben den hebel boden schiebe ich jetzt
haus
dann auf meine tortenplatte und dann
kann ich mithilfe einer palette
tortenplatte wecken
und jetzt kann ich schon verlieren jetzt
schneidig die torte das törtchen den pal
die tat wie auch immer an
ich habe immer noch kein mensch aber was
coco findig trinkgut was jetzt hier so
aussieht wie kleine feine härchen das
sind die faser mit von der ananas
die kann man natürlich weg bekommen
indem man die pürierte anderes durch den
sieg streiten aber ich finde das gehört
einfach mit dazu
und da der herr moore hat gerade mich da
hilft probiere ich sehe jetzt einfach
sehr frischen also die touch mac [ __ ]
erfrischend und ihr müsst auf jeden fall
einfach mal beim pürieren der ananas und
beim berühren mit der maus capone
schauen wie viel salat oder wie viel
saft stoppt ihr benötigt viel braucht
man nämlich wirklich nicht ich hatte
jetzt die ganze packung mit dabei habe
ja auch noch mal nach gefüllt mit ein
bisschen sirup und bei mir passt die
konsistenz wirklich sehr gut falls sie
jetzt keinen sirup matter habt oder
keinen ananassaft dann nehmt ihr einfach
ein bisschen weniger sagt stopp und ist
wirklich hervorragend und dafür dass es
wirklich war es jetzt fünf minuten oder
zehn minuten ich glaube fünf minuten
zubereitung ist wirklich super super
lecker vor allem sehr frischen durch die
ananas und auf jeden fall lohnenswert
nachzumachen
falls ihr das versetzt sucht findet ihr
es auf meinem blog auf settings blog.de
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen ich nehme jetzt noch
einkaufen unterstützen kuchen und matsch
haben also bis zum nächsten mal
und jetzt ist egal ob es zwischen den
zähnen hängt oder
[Musik]
[Applaus]